Hmm.
Anyways,
Jacobs smart enough to get out there and
which is also not really a testament to
his integrity.
Right?
I mean he's done these terrible things
at the behest of his mother because he
wants power and he wants to
get it without deserving it.
And then he finally goes too far and
he hightails it out of there to his,
to another family member,
to his mother's brother.
And so
it's not exactly the
world's most heroic story,
that's for sure.
And so now there's an interlude here,
and this is a really
interesting interlude.
It's,
it's the story of Jacob's ladder.
So he's off to visit La
band or lab and who's,
uh,
his,
his mother's brother and on the way he,
he,
he has a sleep and he lighted upon a
certain place and tarried there all night
because the sun was sad and he took of
the stones of that place and put them for
his pillows,
which seems to indicate
very bad planning on,
on his part and,
and lay down in that place to sleep.
And he dreamed and behold a
ladder set up on the earth.
And the top of it reached to heaven and
beheld the angels of God ascending and
descending on it.
And behold the lord
stood above it and said,
I am the Lord God of Abraham,
thy father and the god of Isaac,
the land we're on Belle liased to
the I will give it and to thy seed.
And so this story of Jacob's ladder has
really possessed the imagination of the
West.
And there's a reason for that.
It's because it's an archetypal story
because the idea of a ladder that reaches
to heaven is one of the
oldest ideas of mankind.
So you'll find it widely distributed
among the shamanic cultures,
for example.
And it's a hallmark of
psychedelic experience.
That's another way of thinking about it,
which is a very peculiar thing.
So there's one representation of,
of the ladder you see
got up at the top there.
I'm peeking out from the clouds.
Now you know that sort of where we get
the idea that God is in heaven and the
heavens up in the sky.
And,
and that's an easy story to
make fun of because you know,
we've gotten up to the moon
and there is no god there and,
and,
but,
but this,
this is not a reasonable way of
conceptualizing what these experiences are
about,
these experiences,
what this is the opening up there that's
more like an opening into an alternate
dimension.
That's a better way of thinking about it.
It's beyond like from,
from the Judeo Christian perspective,
one of the things you have to understand
is that God is beyond space and time.
He's not in the universe,
he's outside the universe in some manner.
And so the idea that that you have an
experience of God and it's op isn't the
APP is the best that the human imagination
can do with what's essentially a form
of extra dimensional experience or
that's the best way to conceptualize it.
And these experiences aren't rare.
You know,
they,
they make the,
they make up the core of,
of the shamanic tradition.
And so there's an intrusion of
the ancient shamanic tradition,
which is tens of thousands of years old
into the biblical stories at this point.
Now why Jacob had a essentially shamonic
experience is very difficult to tell
because we don't know what
these old people we're up to.
Right,
and we don't know how much
of the Archaic Tradition,
archaic,
religious tradition was still extent
at that at that point in time,
but we certainly do know that our
ancient forebears were using psychedelic
substances constantly
like am Anita Mascara,
mushrooms,
for example,
which were widely used in India
before they became extinct.
That's the theory.
Anyways,
that seemed to be the
basis of the Chemical Soma,
which a much has been written about,
and so we hear this as a dream or has a
vision and perhaps that's what it was,
but perhaps that wasn't what it was either
and perhaps it was an experience that
was induced by I by the same processes
that shamonic people have always induced
these experiences and so we're going
to go through this a little bit.
So anyways,
there's A.
There's a connection between
heaven and earth that opens up.
That's,
that's,
that's the,
that's the vision and there's
messenger is moving up and down.
Now,
one way you can conceptualize
that is psychologically,
as we already discussed,
that you know,
there,
there are forces within you that are
active and alive and you can think of them
in some sense as messengers of the higher
self and so you could think about this
as an image of a psychological reality,
but and so we can stick with that,
but,
but
here's some of the representations
that have been made.
I really liked the one on the right.
That's William Blake.
I liked the a helix idea and I
don't think that that's a fluke.
There are helixes and double
helix is in all sorts of images,
imagery,
very ancient and very modern that are
associated with both healing and with this
kind of vision.
So,
and you see it in the
blake representation.
God is associated with,
well really with the sun and with light,
and you see that on the left as well,
that wherever God is is where light is.
And so that's a very interesting
idea as far as I'm concerned as well.